du glaubst es wird ein ganz schön
schwieriger Winter vor allem wenn dann
ist wirklich so weit kommt dass wir die
drei akads in einen Winterschlaf
versetzen dass dieser Winter noch
einigermaßen gut verlaufen wird aber wir
müssen genau wir müssen ja weiter
schauen und was ganz interessant ist wir
sehen hier ein paar Bilder ähm wer nicht
nur in Berlin wohnt aber insgesamt hier
im Norden Deutschland so im Osten der
stellt fest seit 10 Tagen eigentlich ist
der Himmel komplett Verfahren es gibt so
gut wie keine Sonne sieht man auch an
den ähm zuständigen
Agenturen und den Daten die es gibt die
genau schauen wie viel solaren Energie
wird aktuell eigentlich produziert und
oder wie viele Stromausfall Energie muss
man sagen will produzieren wir haben das
gleiche Problem beim Wind wir haben eine
sehr sehr Windstille Tage mal wieder ein
bisschen mehr mal gar nicht äh sowas so
machen müssen wir feststellen dass wir
zum Teil mehr als 80% des Stroms aus
Kohle aktuell erzeugen aus Gas und aus
Kernkraft und das nun schon seit zehn
Tagen das wirft die Frage auf wie soll
das eigentlich werden in einigen Jahren
wenn die Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet
sind und auch die Kohlekraftwerke
abgeschaltet sind wo bekommen wir
eigentlich dann einen Großteil des
Stroms produziert in einer ganz normalen
winterwetterlage wie wir sie aktuell
haben dunkelflaute ist das Stichwort und
diese Frage haben wir auch den Sprecher
von Bundeswirtschaftsminister und dem
klimaschutzminister Robert habe gestellt
auch auf mehrere mehrfachen Nachfrage
wurde unseren Kollegen nicht richtig
erklärt wo denn eigentlich künftig der
Strom herkommen soll das ist unter
anderem wolle konkrete Wetterlagen nicht
kommentieren ja wir haben aber eine
konkrete Wetterlage und die ist gar
nicht ungewöhnlich für den Winter die
ist sogar ziemlich normal also ich
glaube dass hier Luke und Druck herrscht
und wir kommen aus der ganzen Sache nur
raus wenn wir hoffentlich die Kohle
nicht zu lange am Netz halten weil sie
dreckig ist aber dass wir die Kernkraft
natürlich länger laufen lassen das heißt
wir müssen jetzt die Brennstäbe
bestellen für die drei meiner die wir
aktuell haben und für hoffentlich
mindestens zwei weitere die wieder ins
Netz gehen müssen das ist ja auch
eigentlich ihre Aufgabe zumindest die
kriegt die FDP die Grünen noch so weit
dass wir das hinkriegen mit den AKW wir
drängen drängen und drängen aber auch
immer das Gefühl dass auch Robert Habeck
uns nicht immer antwortet ähnliche
offensichtlich wieder Bildredaktion aber
so können wir es ja nicht lassen also
wie weit geht die FDP dann ist es haut
hier wirklich mal auf den Tisch kommt es
vielleicht sogar dazu dass die Koalition
dann auseinanderbricht dass man sagt
dann können wir leider nicht mehr
mitmachen wie weit eskalieren ich hoffe
dass wir das relativ weit hoch ist
skalieren es ist und das haben sie
völlig richtig gesagt eine Frage der
Versorgungssicherheit die wir in diesem
Land unbedingt brauchen wir können uns
nicht vorstellen was es bedeutet wenn
wir ein Blackout haben da gibt es ja
Szenarien auch Studien was dazu
befürchten ist innerhalb von wenigen
Stunden also sind Szenarien die die
wollen wir in diesem Land nicht haben im
Dunkeln sitzen verlassen Sie die
Regierung verstanden
echtes versorgungsdrama rein was den
Strom
Grundproduktion angeht ganz klar also
wir reden über diesen Winter über den
nächsten sind dann einigermaßen sicher
nein wir müssen eigentlich über die Zeit
reden für die Robert habe ich vorgesehen
hat das 80% des Stroms in Deutschland
aus erneuerbaren Energien kommen und wir
das ohne Kernkraft und Kohle hier selbst
produziert im Land hinbekommen sollen da
ist die große Frage und darauf hat
Robert Habeck nur vernebelungs Antworten
bisher übrig wie wird das Laufen da
heißt es dann ja dann gehen die E-Autos
die aufgeladen sind wieder ans Netz und
Speise wieder Strom zurück ein ja ich
meine das ist alles toll der Theorie
oder wir haben dann die Biomasse und so
weiter und so fort nein wir haben ein
Kernproblem wir sind ein Industrieland
und wir brauchen ganz ganz viel Strom
perspektivisch wenn wir 15 Millionen
E-Autos 20 30 haben wollen wie die
Regierung auch sagt brauchen wir
perspektivisch viel viel mehr Strom als
heute wo soll der Bitte herkommen und
die Antwort ist bisher Nebel und das
macht mir richtig Sorgen